welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilshire host and our guest is
Bradley Woodworth he is the coordinator
of Baltic Studies at Yale University and
his research interests include the
modern history of the Baltic region
particularly the lands that today
comprised the Republic of Estonia his
most recent publications deal with music
associations and national identity and
Estonian areas in the 19th century the
multi-ethnic Czarist era bureaucracy in
the Baltic region and the Finnish
general and statesman Gustav Mannerheim
today we'll talk with professor
Woodworth about the Baltic Studies
program at the Macmillan Center welcome
professor Woodward thank you for
inviting me let's start with a little
geography lesson tell us what countries
comprise the Baltic area so it depends
on the perspective that you take when
you when you consider this region if you
look at it as a geographic region that
the Baltic Sea region then these are the
countries that geographically border on
the Baltic Sea so it's a it's a list of
nine countries including countries that
we often think of part of Scandinavia
Finland and Sweden or Central Europe
Germany and Poland but if we consider it
from a political perspective a
geopolitical perspective a modern one
then the term Baltic countries or Baltic
States refers to these three countries
of Lithuania Latvia and Estonia which
had all been part of the Russian Empire
became independent in the course of
World War one and then built States
independent states that existed in the
interwar period okay and what led you to
be interested in studying this area of
the world
well it's a bit of a long story but in
in brief as an undergraduate I spent
time in Finland and learned Finnish
which was kind of odd but it changed my
life and then
I studied Estonian at the University as
well though my major field was was was
Russian so I knew I was interested in
the peoples of that region of the world
northeastern Europe it's a multi-ethnic
it's always has been a multi-ethnic
region and then I completed a PhD in the
history of that region region writing a
dissertation about social and political
change in the city that is now the
capital of Estonia in the night writing
about the 19th and early 20th century
and that is Tollan so I was there in the
early let's see that was the very end of
the Soviet period and it really changed
my life as I learned the line I knew the
languages that the people spoke in there
and then came back to write the doctoral
dissertation 10 years later it must have
been a very interesting time to be there
with all of this it was more than
interesting it's made me who I am as a
person I think ok and so you've been at
Yale overseeing the Baltic Studies
program since 2007 that's right okay and
how gone fast yes it goes by in a blink
so tell us about the program well the
program megan lee has two aspects the
first well first i'd like to say that
that program exists because of the
incredible generosity of a number of
Yale alumni okay and if I can I would
decided to they know that I'm very good
and yet Yale is very grateful for their
generosity but the first is a graduate
of Yale in economics from Lithuania 1951
his name is Joseph Cosette's 'kiss lived
a long and amazing life born in 1918 and
just died five years ago
also dr. Chris Taub sketchy who is a as
a retired physician an orthopedic
surgeon is and has status as a as a as a
retired professor at Yale he came to
this country as a little bit younger
person then then mr. Kazu circus came
with his family fleeing Soviet invasion
I graduated from Yale College and then
Yale Medical School in the 1950s
and then also doctor doctor uterus
paddocks who also Gretel from who was
from Latvia and came as it as a young
person graduated from Yale College and
the Yale then Yale Law School and all of
them have been very he passed away
several years ago
all of them and their families I'm
especially grateful to the siblings of
the kiss kiss family all of them have
really made this program part of their
legacy they were all interested in
continuing the study of their their
homelands I'm loving their homelands and
yet all of them loving Yale as well so
creating a Baltic Studies program was a
way to combine these two you are these
two loves that's wonderful so let's talk
about the program what are some of the
yeah so we have two aspects one there's
a set of postdoctoral fellowships for
citizens of these three countries and
then the second main aspect is we
organize symposia conferences bringing
scholars to to yell to speak to to the
community so let's see about these about
these fellowships they began in 2013 I
went to the Baltic region in a couple
years before that to to find out exactly
how these donors money could best and
the best help that the both Yale
University also those countries all of
them saw these fellowships as a way to
bring talented young academics from the
Baltic region give them experience at
Yale University and in the United States
and then have that added burnish 'men
that at that act that that added part of
their careers enable them to to do even
greater things
how many postdocs cuz we've had 16 have
every year well so we have the two
fellowships one named after dr. Koh's
it's cos who or that is that fellowship
is for citizens of Lithuania the other
fellowship named after you respond X is
for citizens either of laughs year for
where he was from or Estonia so the
number of scholars varies a little bit
every year because we have we have funds
to have two people for the full year but
sometimes the pain
on the length of time that a scholar
would like to stay sometimes they don't
know they only can stay for one semester
so we have varied between two and even
in even four we've had for this last
year and we'll have three in the coming
year all told we have brought to yell
sixteen people from the Baltic countries
seven from Lithuania five from lat five
from Estonia and four from Latvia and do
they do research while they're here and
do they also teach classes it's it is
only research they are reefs they are
they are research fellowships that is
what we want them to do we want them to
further their projects most of them are
working on a book a book project and
there are very few requirements of the
fellowship I feel like also on hoping
that people will will watch us and also
be interested in having this amazing
experience I mean the fellows come
usually not having visited Yale before
and it this is an amazing place and the
things that you can do and the people
that you can meet really really are go
beyond what the fellows had even
imagined could happen but all we require
is that they they give a presentation at
the end of their stay about their
research and then just spend all of
their time working so it's not a
Teaching Fellowship just research okay
and what are the scholars working on who
are here now what are their problems
well we have so we've had three that
that have been here earlier this year
and have now left we had uhand Helena
Montana stone Ian who is a philosopher I
was working on issues of temporality
which I tried to understand from his
from his presentation and then we had a
new PhD from Latvia Maya spore Tina who
looks at national memory in Latvia is
particularly interested in in some of
the darker parts of of Baltic history
there well there was a rise of
authoritarian political authoritarianism
in the 1930s and then all three
countries particularly with away Nia but
also Latvia were devastated by the
Holocaust all of all of the countries
had Jewish populations and those
populations
completely decimated over the course of
the war
so she studies that the issues connected
to what Latvia is today in its picture
it's its self-image
in light of that past and we have to so
she was from the Latvian we've had two
Lithuanians mundaka shop mint algis shop
oka who studies a ward that I think if
you in this country heard of is called
the great northern war it was the first
quarter of the 18th century and it was
how could I what what could I say about
it as a war that that actually
diminished Sweden's power Sweden used to
be in the 18th century a great world
power and at the same time Russia then
rose under the Peter the Great to become
the the major power that it did in the
18th and 19th century so he said he said
he's that war is working on a on a new
history so he was here for most of the
year and just left and we have one
lithuanian still here her name is Monica
Monica Connard anyhow kitei and she
studies criminality both in Lithuania in
the Soviet Union so she'll be giving a
presentation in about a month ok and
we're at the end of the school year
there's spring semester I'm wondering if
you have identified the people who will
become yeah I mean actually this will be
the first time we've publicly announced
it although I've let the because it's
cos family no because we have two
Lithuanians coming in January
stanislovas stasulis who is a historian
and he'll be studying the memory of the
Holocaust in Lithuania both from the
period of the war and to the present and
then we have a story we have a political
science political scientist coming they
meet that Vitalis watch this and he's
interested in very different issues a
political economist really and is
interested in in in currency reform and
how in the Baltic region the political
the economic crises of this past decade
had been dealt with and then in the fall
we're bringing an Estonian here
marlis Jacobsen and she's interested in
voting patterns of Estonians who do not
live in Estonia and so in Estonia as
well as other Baltic countries peoples
who are of that ethnicity have a have
voting rights but she's interested in
why so few of the Estonians who could
participate in the in these extra torrid
extraterritorial elections do not in
fact do so so she's interested in sort
of a a worldwide phenomenon the spread
of Estonians throughout other parts of
the world okay so what does the future
hold for Baltic Studies how would you
like to see the program expand well in
the coming two years we're going to be
expanding particularly with regard to
programs we're going to hold now that
we've had 16 wonderful young scholars
come to Yale this fall in November we're
going to have our first reunion oh I'm
very excited about it
because while we in the Macmillan Center
have been able to meet all of these
scholars and become friends with them
some of them know each other but not
that many so we what we'd really like to
do is have a network right of young
scholars throughout the Baltic region
all of whom have had this amazing
experiences yeah yeah and so and then at
the same time will bring members of the
families of our donors so they can be
able to meet meet these scholars
exciting yeah and then in the spring
we're going to hold a conference about
documents that the KGB left behind at
the end of the Soviet Union that's what
all these three countries regain their
independence in 1990 in 1991 this past
December of a fairly large tranche of
documents were really discovered and
within in Latvia there not been
seriously they looked at before and a
lot of these that were left by the KGB
and a lot of these documents have the
names of fairly prominent people within
Latvia in other words at least the KGB
was saying we have contacts with with
many of your citizens so what we'd like
to do in this conference it will be
either January or February is bring
specialists who know these documents
firsthand that the number of Latvian
historians are in the process of of
publishing some of these documents for
the first time and then talk about the
way to decide
have dealt with this is this is this
dark inheritance have you seen any of
the documents yourself
I haven't now what happened so it'll be
a new area for me my researches you
discussed in the beginning has been with
the period over a hundred years ago in
the Czar's theory and earlier and then
later in 2020 in the fall I'll be
collaborating with the leading
Lithuanian historian gaudiest Ali on us
at the Lithuanian Institute of history
to have a two-day conference in which we
will re-examine the issue of multi
ethnicity this this region is inherently
a multi-ethnic region even though today
these three countries carry the names of
a particular ethnic group as
nation-states the populations that have
lived there have always been mixed
ethnically and also religiously and
linguistically so we'd like to see if we
can come up with a new way of looking at
this region it is not predetermined by
the ideologies of either nationalism or
an imposed Soviet friendship of people's
right sounds like a lot of good things
to come for Baltic study so we will look
forward to seeing more from you in the
in the near future thank you for being
here with us thank you very much okay
for more information about Professor
Woodworth and his research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
thank you so much thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]